[Music]
Europe is a dynamic political project
and there are many changes to which we have
to adapt
[Music]
the conference on the future of Europe is
a space for debate and reflection, a
space open to European citizens
to face the challenges and changes
that  europe needs the most
positive aspect of this conference is to open a
debate to all European citizens and to
do it in a way in which the majority
of citizens can participate outside
the European bubble outside the
institutions the role
of citizens  it is essential they
must be the protagonists of this
conference and that is why the
participation channels are necessary
and essential through a
digital platform where
spontaneous debates of
citizens who want to talk about
health about youth and about the
european culture is the moment of
listening is the moment of
participation for men and
women in europe  they can participate and
say the europe we want to build
together the future
and senior hans
[Music]